[Aplausos]
buenas tardes
yo voy a empezar con una pregunta
cuántas veces nos hemos sentido juzgados
por la música que nos gusta escuchar o
por nuestros gustos en general
muchas verdad porque además yo soy
músico y ha sido músico desde que tengo
memoria y conozco muy bien esos juicios
no solo porque me han juzgado a mí
muchas veces sino porque para ser
honesto yo he juzgado muchísimas veces
pero en algún momento de mi vida
afortunadamente decidí que me quería
convertir en un músico sin apellido y
amo lo que eso ha traído a mi vida y les
quiero contar un poco cómo ha sido ese
proceso que empecé en mi vida con la
guitarra creo que tenía tal vez siete
años cuando empecé a tocar mis padres
nunca me compraron una guitarra para mi
tamaño sino que me compraron la guitarra
normal y me tocaba tocar guitarra así
pero por ahí empecé y empecé a construir
toda mi identidad alrededor de la
guitarra crecí salí del colegio y empecé
a estudiar una carrera de guitarra jazz
y todo lo que yo era era guitarrista y
cuando me presentaban yo era guitarrista
y era músico y tocaba bien y me estaba
yendo bien pero de repente en algún
momento me crucé con la dirección de
orquesta y encontré en la dirección de
orquesta algo que nunca había sentido
tocando guitarra y me enamoré
perdidamente de esa profesión y más o
menos en octavo semestre de carrera de
guitarra jazz tomé la decisión de
retirarme para convertirme en un
director de orquesta imagínense la
disonancia imagínense la locura como así
que este tipo que toca guitarra ni
siquiera clásica toca guitarra jazz y
toca rock y toca pop de un momento a
otro a sus 22 años decide dejar botado
un proceso de más de 15 años para
empezar casi desde cero es una nueva
carrera para mí fue difícil para mis
padres fue extraño para mis colegas era
absolutamente incomprensible esa
decisión pero la tomé y empezó a
construir me como director de orquesta
y lo primero con lo que me encuentro es
un profesor que me dice en la nueva
universidad bueno yo está que viene y yo
le digo demostrar dirección de orquesta
bueno usted es pianista no
violinista tampoco algún instrumento de
cuerda de guitarra clásica no
y entonces usted que hace aquí
viene a aprender dirección de orquesta
sí y tuve que empezar a abrirme camino
en esta nueva carrera y empecé a
encontrarme con un montón de esquemas
nuevos que yo no conocía porque ya en la
guitarra me había encontrado con unos
cuantos resulta que en la universidad
que yo estudiaba guitarra había ciertos
artistas que no estaba tan chévere que
yo escuchará y yo empecé a dejar de
escucharlos porque el entorno me decía
que no servían que no se valían esos
gustos y en denver y además empecé a
notar que había una cierta forma de
comportarse que se valía y una cierta
forma que no dentro de la facultad de
jazz y tenía que ajustar mi
comportamiento a eso para ser aceptado y
cuando lo logró me voy a estudiar
dirección de orquesta y me encuentro con
otra serie de paradigmas y con otra
serie de comportamientos que estaban
bien y otra serie comportamientos que
estaban mal y entonces los vídeos en los
que yo aparecía tocando guitarra
no estaba tan chévere que los vieran mis
compañeros y mucho menos mis profesores
y para colmo un par de años dentro de la
carrera de guitarra de dirección de
orquesta un amigo mío me pone encima un
tiple
es muy parecido a la guitarra pero el
pequeño tiene dos cuerdas del
instrumento típico colombiano y por
alguna razón apenas me lo puse y empecé
a tocar se sintió bien
me sentí como en casa
y entonces ahora yo era un guitarrista
que dejó de ser guitarrista para
volverse un director y que por el lado
estaba tocando tiple y entonces cómo
funciona eso y entonces quién eres tú y
cómo te ves vestir y cómo te debes
comportar porque si quieres preguntar a
estos dos cuál es el director de
orquesta
verdad es absolutamente claro basta con
ver una imagen de nuestro cerebro
inmediatamente saca una serie
conclusiones y pareciera como si
existiera una relación entre la música
que escuchas o que haces y cuál es tu
personalidad cuáles son los códigos de
comportamiento y cuál es tu identidad y
para mí eso se convirtió en un problema
porque tenía más o menos tres entidades
distintas conviviendo en mí y entonces
viene la pregunta de qué se vale que
está bien y qué está mal para dónde
tengo que ir porque el entorno cuando
estaba por la noche tocando en guitarra
me decía una cosa pero durante el día
estudiando piano y estoy en dirección de
orquesta me decía otra entonces para
dónde voy cuál es mi norte porque sucede
que en las carreras de música clásica tú
empiezas a estudiar música desde que
tienes desde que la música estaba más o
menos hace unos 500 años y se supone que
tú en 5 años de carrera tienes que
entender 500 años de música y un poco
más porque si tienes algún profesor que
le parece interesante la música griega
1500 años más de historia y está
perfecto que mires para atrás pero si
miras para el lado para tocar ti player
es director de orquesta eso no se vale
entonces cómo funciona cuál es la lógica
porque yo no estaba pueden entenderlo y
me empiezo a dar cuenta de que muchas de
las cosas que a mí me enseñaban en la
universidad cuando estaba estudiando
música clásica yo ya las había aprendido
cuando estudia guitarra jazz pero se
llamaban distinto entonces el profesor
me explicaba algo violencia así si yo sé
yo sé qué es eso eso es tal cosa y le
llamaba con el nombre que no era me
decía no eso está mal así el fenómeno
musical fuera el mismo y así su función
dentro de la música fuera la misma pero
el ambiente en el que lo estaba diciendo
cambiaba entonces yo tenía que cambiar
mi forma de entenderlo pero por qué pero
porque ese es el mismo fenómeno y
empiezo a notar cosas como la manera la
manera es un ritmo que es una yum
[Música]
si es un ritmo que es panamericanos de
hecho es casi mundial en casi todas las
músicas del mundo se encuentra este tipo
de ritmo y un cutting con mucha de
nuestra música lo tiene y creo que se
fijen en esto esto es nace supuestamente
en cuba por eso le llaman así aunque no
aunque nadie está seguro pero si yo
tengo wow
whiting con un ping kong
resulta que en francia bizet compuso una
ópera que se llama carmen y esa ópera
tiene un área que empieza con christina
kim dong-jin kim hyun
[Música]
verdad todo lo hemos escuchado porque
más es en propagandas con esa y resulta
que si yo como la misma manera y hago
por una cabeza
de repente tengo un tango y es la misma
manera en la mitad
que empieza a sonar un poquito como
bachata y si lo hago un poquito más
rápido y un poquito más agresivo
wang yuqing
[Música]
llegamos sin darnos cuenta la fruta
prohibida de la música
el reggaeton
y entonces resulta que la línea que
conecta una de las óperas más famosas de
la historia con el reggaetón es
relativamente corta y bastante diré que
está al parecer y como este existen
muchos otros mecanismos musicales que
están en muchos tipos de música pero que
los percibimos como si fueran totalmente
lejanos y les quiero mostrar una cosa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
ay
lo que acabamos de ver son dos escenas
una en la película de tiburón y otra
película de la guerra de las galaxias'
de star wars pero yo reemplace la música
y le puse un par de sinfonías de un
compositor checo que se llama antonio
vojak
pero es casi imperceptible el cambio
suenan bien son coherentes pero pero
entonces
si yo crecí percibiendo la música
clásica como algo absolutamente aburrido
y si cuando a mí me decían música
clásica yo me imaginaba un tipo con unas
medias más o menos hasta aquí y con una
peluca blanca tocando en un auditorio
cómo va a ser posible que esa música me
funcione para ponérselo a una escena de
unas películas de acción
será que es que quizás no es ni tan
aburrida ni tan ajena ni tan lejana ni
tan extraña como hemos pensado que es
resulta que voy a que es una de las
grandes influencias que tuvo john
williams el compositor de esas dos
soundtracks de esas dos películas
resulta que bajo la forma en la que él
componía su música es muy similar a la
forma en la que funciona el jazz
y de hecho hay proyectos que cogen la
música de bach y la reinterpreta de
manera
[Música]
así
son acordes
[Música]
abajo
ah
[Música]
hola
frente
aún así
[Música]
una canción muy famosa que se llamaba
gimeno traver y que en estas épocas
afortunadamente está muy de moda pero si
uno va a analizar qué es una rapsodia
resulta con la rapsodia es una pieza
musical formada con fragmentos de otras
obras o con trozos de aires populares y
si uno escucha esa canción parece que
fueran como cinco canciones metidas en
una no nos aparecía que fueron a
rapsodia
pero es como pop es como más relajada es
como si fuera bohemia o no
y durante toda la canción hace alusiones
a cosas de la ópera figaro es un
personaje de una ópera que se llama el
barbero de sevilla que es el
protagonista y es un personaje que es
súper icónico hay otra ópera de mozart
que se llama las bodas del fígaro habla
de magnífico otro personaje del barbero
de sevilla pero es queen y es rock
entonces cómo funciona eso porque además
si yo les muestro ustedes esta foto y yo
les digo que él es músico que busque
música se imaginan ustedes qué hace él
pareciera que fuera como un guitarrista
de bossa nova o de pronto el primo de
james blunt o algo por el estilo o no
pero resulta que él es un pianista que
se llama james rhodes y él se dedica a
tocar música clásica y eso que ustedes
ven ahí es su etiqueta el sabe tocar los
conciertos exactamente así como ustedes
lo ven ocasionalmente la camiseta tiene
escrito aquí baja pero nada más
y para él la música es eso él de hecho
dice en uno de sus libros que si
beethoven fuera a ver un concierto de
música clásica en la que están tocando
su música le parecería absolutamente
ridículo que saliera una cantidad de
personas con esmoquin a tocar su música
y les quiero contar una cosa berlíoz o
un compositor francés de música clásica
y es una sinfonía que se llama la
sinfonía fantástica que es una sinfonía
sobre una persona sobre un hombre que
consume un ácido y empieza a alucinar y
la historia que el tipo alucina es que
tiene a su novia a la vez se sienta
enamorado de ella en un baile empieza a
sentir que eres demasiado perfecta para
estar con él tiene un ataque de celos la
mata lo cogen y lo matan a él
y en la sinfonía tú puedes escuchar el
momento en el que la guillotina baja y
el momento en que la cabeza cae
y nosotros salimos en esmoquin a tocar
esto se dan cuenta del divorcio que hay
entre la música y la forma en la que la
presentamos quiero que vean esta otra
foto teodor currentzis
director de orquesta y no cualquier
director es uno de los mejores
directores formales de orquesta que hay
en el mundo en este momento y así como
lo ven dirige algunos conciertos
entonces qué tan diferentes son en
realidad estos tipos de música que tan
diferentes son las personas que hacen un
tipo de música u otro parece que no
tanto pero si no tanto entonces porque
las percibimos como si fueran tan
diferentes
yo tengo una teoría y es que es culpa
del ritual el ritual es una serie de
comportamientos y de cosas que haces
alrededor de algo verdad y que por lo
general tiene un valor en sí mismo
cuando uno va a una ceremonia religiosa
es eso es un ritual porque hay una
cierta tipo de cosas que tienes que
hacer y yo creo que nosotros le hemos
dado mucha importancia el ritual que
está detrás de los tipos de música
porque ir a un teatro escuchar música
clásica en donde sabes que te tienes que
ir más o menos bien vestido en el que te
tienes que sentar en silencio y a pesar
de sentirte muy emocionado no puedes
aplaudir porque te hacen
eso es un ritual y se ha convertido más
importante el ritual que la música y eso
es cierto con el rock con el metal con
el jazz con absolutamente todo y también
creo que nosotros tenemos una búsqueda
absolutamente inútil de lo puro tenemos
una fantasía de lo puro no es que yo soy
músico clásico entonces ahora que
escucho música clásica esta es la
expresión más pura del barroco que ese
jazz fussion nos sirva y me gusta el
jazz que es puro el bebop que lo puro no
existe lo puro no existe y esa fantasía
de lo de lo puro nos ha causado guerras
mundiales en este planeta pero nosotros
no nos sirve para nada porque por más
puro que tú creas que sea algo que
encontraste basta con dar un paso más
para atrás y vas a encontrar un
mestizaje y resulta que el mestizaje es
mágico y es poderoso lo podemos ver por
ejemplo en los perros los perros que son
de raza raza raza raza son mucho más
susceptibles a tener enfermedades
genéticas mientras que los perros que
son criollos o mestizos
inmunes inmunológicamente mucho más
fuertes tienen menos enfermedades una
cantidad de cosas el mestizaje es
absolutamente puro pero además en este
punto perdón es mágico pero además es
inevitable lo quieras o no entonces te
quiero preguntar cuáles apellidos tienes
tú cuáles apellidos te has permitido a
ti ponerte soy ingeniero y entonces me
porto de esta manera y me he visto de
esta manera soy médico y entonces soy
así y no hago esto porque cuántos
apellidos te has puesto tú
yo siento que hay que quitarse los
apellidos que nos estorban si te sirven
para entenderte maravilloso pero que no
te limiten porque entonces tu actitud
frente a lo desconocido va a ser
equivocada y yo creo que ya es hora de
que nosotros empecemos como humanidad a
quitarnos los apellidos y empezar a
construir una forma nueva de
relacionarnos con ese otro es utópico
claro es difícil mucho pero creo que es
una posibilidad que vale la pena
explorar y qué mejor lugar para hacerlo
que la música muchas gracias
[Aplausos]